Hey, what's up guys
I brought you out to the mountains tonight because there's a cool little trick that I want to show you that involves juggling fire
So what are you doing over here, buddy?
Uh, looking for diamonds
All right, i'm going to go back to the fire
Quick update guys, our fire is rocking! If you come down here you can see some of the coals down here you can see that they are turning bright bright
Now, the idea of this fire over here is I want that thing to burn until its got a lot of glowing red hot coals.
Now that's gonna take a few minutes, so in the meantime
We're just hanging out having dinner
This tastes so good
our fire is burning down. Look at those coals
I've hit 'em a few times with the marshmallow roasting sticks just to break them up into little rock sized chunks
There is still enough residual heat here that it's very, very difficult  to get any closer than about 3 feet
If you look close you can probably see like im dripping sweat
That's how hot it is, like.
In just a second I'm gonna reach my hand into there, pull out one of those hot coals and try and juggle them for  ya
So the principle we're going to be battling against here is the dissipation of heat. The coals are extremely hot way higher than the melting point of my skin
Now it does take a little bit of work to get the coal out of the fire, you might actually just wanna pick one up and throw it right onto the ground first just so you can better leverage yourself to pick it up and get it onto your hand
Alright guys, the time has come you can see the fire's pretty much burnt down, we've got a nice bed of coal in there, they're glowing orange.
The trick to making this work are lightening fast reflexes. I have to reach in there, grab a coal and be back out before the fire has a chance to burn the hair off my skin
oooh that a big one, lets check this out
There we go
Check out what happens when i blow on it
Now the first step is to actually figure out which coal you wanna go for because you need to pre-determine which one you're going to grab
For me I'm kinda thinking that one right there, which is extremely hot. So I'm gonna back up, let my hands cool off for just a second. Then i'm going to dive right in and grabit
Once it actually hits the hand you can see as long as you move it quickly enough it doesn't sit in one spot long enough to actually burn you.
Once you understand the limits of nature and respect those boundaries you can bend the limits and play with fire without getting burnt
woops, you can see it broke into three pieces there and i still got one of them here. Look at that
See this is actually easier than shaking it with your fingers closed
But this way you can see it adds oxygen and get it glowing nice red and hot
I did this with quite a few different coals and come look at my hands. Come check this out. You can see they are a little bit blackened from charcoal  but there are no burn marks.
Yes my skin feels a little bit tingly. There were a few times that the coal caught up and did sting me but that's not going to leave any blisters, that's not going to do any damage because the coal never actually sat there long enough to burn the skin.
So there you have it guys, that is how you play with fire without getting burnt.
It's been awesome hanging out with you tonight and i'll be looking for you in the next random adventure. I'll see you there.
Byeee
You find any diamonds?
found none